[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben nachdem ein tiramisu
rezept so gut bei euch angekommen ist
habe ich mir gedacht es wird zeit für
tiramisu cupcakes die cupcakes bestehen
aus einem boden außen löffelbiskuits
außerdem einem leckeren kaffee macht
indem man auch gerne durch schoko
muffins ersetzen kann und aus einer
mascarpone seine schicht als topping für
die allererste schicht benötigen wir
löffelbiskuits und geschmolzene butter
die löffelbiskuits werden jetzt fein
gemahlen und dann geht es auch schon
weiter
wer so ein sehr kleiner grab nicht da
hat der kann die löffelbiskuits auch in
einen gefrierbeutel tun und dann mit dem
nudelholz solange draufschlagen bis sie
schön feiern werden wenn sie nicht ganz
so fein werden ist es auch nicht so
schlimm aber dann habt ihr einen
schöneren boden
[Musik]
zu den löffelbiskuits gebe ich jetzt
noch die geschmolzene butter und verriet
dass gut miteinander
die masse gäbe ich kurz an die seite und
wir machen weiter mit dem muffin wir
benötigen weiche butter zucker außerdem
eier mehl etwas backpulver und kaffee
wer den kaffee nicht möchte der kann das
ganze auch durch milch ersetzen der
muffin teig ist auch super schnell
zubereitet gegeben zuallererst die
weiche butter mit dem zucker in eine
große schüssel und verrühren das gut mit
dem handmixer
[Musik]
nach etwa drei minuten geben wir
nacheinander die zwei eier in die
schüsse und hier ist es auch besser wenn
die eier zimmertemperatur haben dann
verbindet sich das besser miteinander
[Musik]
nun geht es weiter mit dem trockenen
zutaten und dem café die trockenen
zutaten also mail bei kakao und
backpulver gebe ich gerne noch mal durch
einen sie damit ich sicherstellen kann
dass auch keine klümpchen im teig
entstehen damit ihr am ende auch einen
schönen lockeren teig erhaltet ist es
jetzt ganz wichtig dass ihr die
trockenen zutaten nicht alle auf einmal
dazu gibt sondern schön abwechselnd mit
dem lauwarmen kaffee
[Musik]
damit ich keinen ganz so starken
kaffeegeschmack habe habe ich hier café
olé genommen also kaffee mit milch
ihr könnt natürlich auch die hälfte
durch milch ersetzen und die andere
hälfte durch espresso
[Musik]
nachdem ihr euch dann nach und nach
durch gearbeitet habt und keine
trockenen zutaten sowie keinen kaffee
mehr habt ist der teig auch schon fertig
den ofen habe ich mir in der
zwischenzeit auch schon vorgeheizt auf
180 grad ober und unterhitze und weiter
geht's mit unserer machen blech und hier
gehen wir zuallererst unseren keks boden
hinein
[Musik]
nachdem alles gleichmäßig in die
förmchen verteilt wurde nehmen wir uns
ein flaches glas und drücken das ganze
damit auf den boden
[Musik]
auf diesem boden geben wird dann den
teig unserer martinz
[Musik]
nun wandern die muffins für 22 minuten
in den vorgeheizten backofen
[Musik]
wenn nach dem backen auch die stäbchen
probe überstanden ist muss das ganze
vollständig auskühlen
[Musik]
für die tiramisu creme benötigen wir
kalte schlagsahne mascarpone doppel
rahmen frischkäse ein wenig puderzucker
zum süßen und seine stand mittel
für die creme geben wir jetzt ganz
einfach die zutaten in unsere
ausreichend große schüssel
ich starte hier mit mascarpone
frischkäse und sahne
[Musik]
dann verrühren wir das ganze mit unserem
handmixer ihr könnt doch gerne die
küchenmaschine verwenden und zwar erst
auf mittlerer stufe dann gehen wir
puderzucker und sahne stand mittel mit
hinzu und dann wird auf höchster stufe
komplett steif geschlagen
[Musik]
die mascarpone creme ist zwar super
schnell hergestellt allerdings solltet
ihr auch beachten dass die zutaten kalt
sind
[Musik]
das war es auch schon mit der
zubereitung der creme und jetzt geht ans
dekorieren meiner meinung nach der
spaßigste teil überhaupt
[Musik]
die creme gebe ich mir jetzt in meinem
spritzbeutel und vorne an den beutel
habe ich eine offene runde tülle wert
die nicht da hat der kann auch ganz
einfach vorne die spitze abschneiden
dann habt ihr den gleichen effekt
[Musik]
hier seht ihr noch mal die töne wie groß
sie ist und anschließend geht es aber
ans dekorieren und das geht auch super
einfach viel für sprit sich einfach
kleine tupfen auf den muffin
[Musik]
anschließend gebe ich bei kakao darüber
das ist ganz typisch für diese tiramisu
optik und ich finde man erkennt schon
das ist dir am besten cupcakes
darstellen soll
[Musik]
diese creme ist super fest und spritz
fähig das heißt wenn ihr eine andere
lieblingsziel habt dann könnt ihr die
auch gerne nehmen und zb auch rosen
stützen
[Musik]
und das war es eigentlich auch schon mit
der zubereitung gekühlt halten sich die
cupcakes bis zu drei tage und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken schaut gerne mal unten die
infobox da habe ich nochmal alle genauen
mengenangaben für euch aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
falls ihr also grundsätzlich schon
tiramisu fans seit genau wie ich dann
macht auf jeden fall nach oder
überrascht eure liebsten damit ich freue
mich wie immer über fotos mit dem
hashtag cities kitchen auf instagram
[Musik]
am ende des videos verlinkt ich euch
noch zwei super geniale rezepte und dann
freue ich mich wenn dem einen kanal
abonniert damit ihnen nichts mehr
verpasst und auch beim nächsten mal
wieder dabei sein
[Musik]